[Music]  after the underground fighting and being  in prison a little bit of ah cheese  innocence is taken away he's not the  same kid from season one that you see  who's trying to figure out what he wants  to do with his life is it music or is it  football our cheese hero journey is  about maintaining his sort of moral  center within these otherwise terrifying  situations and narrative ly that's what  he's coming to terms with either holding  on to or losing across this season the  stakes are a little higher for him at  the moment which is you know for me as  an actor the material that I'm getting  to play with at the moment is is amazing  I'm so lucky to be able to sink my teeth  into something that challenges me and  that physically challenges me mentally  challenges me emotionally challenges me  and it's fun but the physical stuff is  just fun I just love it that's pretty  much what I want to be doing at the  motor  you  [Music]  [Applause]